find the area of a square with side 6x
minus 5y so if you have a square all the
sides are going to be the same length
and they're telling us the length is 6x
minus 5y the length or the height will
also be 6x minus 5y and if you wanted to
find the area of the square you just
multiply the width times the height or
you would multiply 6x minus 5y times 6x
minus 5y or another way to think about
it is you're taking 6x minus 5y you're
taking 6x minus 5y to the second power
or you're taking 6x minus 5y squared
that's why squaring something means or
that's why raising something to the
second power is called squaring it
because you're essentially finding the
area of a square you're thinking you're
going from one dimension to two
dimensions that's where the term squared
comes from now when you square something
you could just do the distributive
property twice like we've done in
several videos but a shortcut when you
square something it all just comes from
working it out by doing the distributive
property twice is you can square the
first term so it'll be 6x squared and
then you could take the product of both
terms and multiply it by 2 so x 2 times
6x times negative 5 y and then you can
square the last term so plus let me do
it a new color plus negative 5y squared
so that's the last term right there this
is the product of both of them you
multiply it by 2
and that will be this quantity squared
and you can get there by just doing the
distributive property twice or foil
however you want to do it but this is a
quicker way if you're one so that when
you see a squared you can immediately
get to this and just working it out you
get 6x squared is 36 x squared right 6
squared times x squared and then let's
see you have a negative let's see 2
times 6 times 5 that is negative 10
times 6 so it's negative 60 negative 60
and then we have an X and a Y X Y all
right we have an X and a y and then all
of the constants when you multiply them
you get negative 60 and then finally you
have it
negative 5y squared so what is what is
negative 5 squared negative 5 squared is
plus 25 positive 25 and then Y squared
is just Y squared and we're done we
found the area of the square with side
6x minus 5y it's represented by this by
this expression right here